anders krankes essen
das riecht brutal geile ja genau das ist
wichtig finden in der ecke aufpassen ein
bisschen was gedacht und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
mir auch wir haben heute strahlend
irgendwie ist er so ein punkt also das
habe ich öfter mal was ist wieder da auf
jeden fall haben wir strahlend blauem
himmel also besonnenheit nicht aber die
sonne strahlt zumindest ich habe heute
auch meine freundin dabei hallo maria
und du bist jetzt mein an den imac dran
und zwar entsteht heute ein kleiner blog
ich habe richtig bock drauf das hat mir
den zuschauererfolg schlagen vor schon
längere zeit ich euch mal kurz worum es
geht und zwar benutzen will also es geht
um es halt mal kurz auf den punkt zu
bringen hat wahrscheinlich am titel auch
schon gelesen
wir benutzen google und tippen in google
zum beispiel jetzt ein also ich weiß
nicht wie lange der block geht auf jeden
fall länger als frühstück sagen aber so
wie er jetzt 10 11 uhr morgens gibt es
jetzt heute zum beispiel ein geiles
frühstück bobby ist irgendwie sowas halt
also kannst kreativ sein und dann gehen
wir auf bilder und das erste bild das
kommt das gibt es dann halt zum
frühstück da steht er also alles was da
drauf ist das gleiche können wir dann
auch noch mit mittagessen machen wir da
haben das sind keine ahnung hatte fanden
auf jeden fall in die stadt jetzt
wahrscheinlich verstand wenn ich's
feiert gibt noch nach oben aber ihr den
kanal jeden tag menschen ein neues video
so also seine aufgabe ist es jetzt hier
genau steht dann mal eben was ein was du
warst du meinst okay jetzt auch bilder
und jetzt hatte sie hat eingeben es ist
frühstück anders heftig die kammer ist
das hier ist das bild was ist das das
ist doch kein problem
doggy bag gastronomen haften nicht für
mitgenommen speisen also ihr könnt hier
sehen das ist das erste foto das ist
doch mehr als einen brunch dingen oder
also ich muss sagen ich hab das noch nie
gesehen dass ich mein köln dahinter
angegeben
wir müssen jetzt schon das ja aber das
ist doch kein frühstück oder also meiner
meinung nach hat das nichts mit politik
zu tun warum auch immer das jetzt kommt
tut mir leid da geht noch was anderes
mit frühstück ein
ihr seid kreativ
das ist doch kein frühstück herrschte
das gar nicht wir geben jetzt mal was
sachlich ist ein leckeres frühstück in
köln
guck mal das sieht doch eigentlich
wollte was ist das sagst dass du geboren
bist ja ein bisschen klein aber so was
habe ich noch nie vergessen hatte ich
mal gucken muss das gibt okay da nehme
ich schon mal das und du suchst jetzt
noch eben was für durchaus gibt noch mal
irgendwas mit frühstück ein comeback das
du magst du das nicht deshalb dass das
einmal ab ocado mit tomaten
also ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt
erst mal frühstücken ich bestelle das
was sie da gefunden habe und ich hoffe
ich habe das vorher wirklich noch nie
gegessen wie ich das noch mal
wie ist das noch mal von mir also wir
nehmen das café das halt dieses bild
gepostet weil wir haben nach köln
besucht und die werden ja auch
reinshagen hoffen falls nicht dann hast
du pech gehabt
christoph nix also ich bin mal gespannt
bis vielleicht wir müssen auf jeden fall
schon das erste nehmen das problem ist
natürlich wenn es das nicht gibt von mir
auch nichts hören
dann müssen wir noch mal muss ich das ja
straße
dann würde ich sagen wir fahren wir noch
mal hin aber ich bin eigentlich so der
fan von selber machen weil dann schmeckt
nicht für gut so leute wir suchen jetzt
mal dieses café was wir da gefunden
haben muss irgendwo hier sein da hinten
[Musik]
so leute es los dann mal
und sagen ich hab gerade so genug gehabt
das ordnungsamt ist genau da hinten die
kommen jetzt hier hin und ich hatte halt
nur so ein parkschein für 20 minuten
waren aber über eine schöne da drin und
ich hab kein knöchel bekommen
man muss aber sagen wie fand sie darin
avocado dinge also meine joghurt die ich
da hatte man nicht so die phase ging
habe ich als folge bauschmerzen davon
weil die so kalt war ein bisschen
komisch bisschen so wie eis joghurt
deswegen habe ich auch noch ein
croissant dazu dann genommen
hier sind sich nie ausreden das wort und
schön dort das ordnungsamt köln jeden
fall beim ein bisschen sauer aber ich
hab' ocado also dieses mottos mit
avocado steht und wir haben gerade als
wir zum
zum kaffee gefallen sind haben wir sonst
übels kräften scooter unfall gesehen da
kamen einer auf dieses guter halt diese
die man mieten kann die elektro scooter
und dann kam halt ein auto ziemlich
schnell und sollte in die tankstelle
einbiegen oder haben sie sich getroffen
und der offenbacher ist ich hab das so
im augenwinkel gesehen
der ist halt wirklich durch die luft
geflogen so fasst 1 52 meter und da hat
sich dann so richtig den bauch gehalten
haben also falls du siehst gute
besserung
leute was geht hertz etwas mit dem
lichten los hallo hier bin ich hier
man verstehe ich nicht wieso dann scharf
stellt also um ehrlich zu sein jetzt
schon mittlerweile nachmittag maries
auch gar nicht mehr dabei die moz zu
arbeiten und ich mache jetzt hier das
video weiter alleine halt weil was
bleibt mir anderes übrig und zwar geht
es jetzt um mittagessen nur leider habe
ich in dieser garage hier kein empfang
deswegen müssen wir jetzt logischerweise
genau rausfahren und hier bin ich ja ich
habe jetzt den plan dass ich hier nicht
statt fahren wollte und mir meinen
mittagessen für heute zu holen ich habe
gerade schon im ersten paar dieses
videos fertig geschnitten ich mache
jetzt hier einfach mal eine
bildschirmaufnahme vom handy und wir
geben mal ein ich hatte gerade irgendwie
so einen gedanken anders krank ist
essen/köln so was richtig brutal geil
also es immer wichtig kölner hinter zu
schreiben damit der automatisch
irgendwie so hier halt sucht und
irgendwas findet was es halt in köln blk
im jänner eine tolle initiative die
durch den magen geht beim einkommen der
nachkochen kölnerinnen und kölner für
flüchtlinge ja gut ich glaube das ist
nichts für mich war also das war
eigentlich ganz lecker aussieht aus als
ich eigentlich aus dem restaurant
also wenn das essen was die für die
kochen so lecker aussieht wird man ja
fast schon neidische okay dann geben wir
jetzt einfach mal ein geiles leckeres
essen köln
okay was sein könnte gut sein so trainer
kummer was haben wir hier das hier ist
ja das erste das sind pommes mit
irgendwas frau
das sieht richtig gut aus und da rechts
haben wir so ein asia teller oder so was
man muss aber ja ganz klar sagen dass
das hier so eigentlich das erste bild
ist ja kann man ja hier ganz gut sehen
das ist das allererste bild von allen
was hier kommt jetzt muss ich nur
herausfinden muss das gefahr ja ok ach
ja das kenne ich sogar ich war da noch
nie
also ohne spaß ich war wirklich dort
noch nicht bin schon zigmal lang
gelaufen habt ihr aber noch nie gegessen
und wir nehmen jetzt eigentlich muss ich
ja auch das also irgendwas davon hört
nehmen ich finde dass unten sie richtig
lecker aus dass und in der mitte kommt
wir fahren jetzt einfach dahin und das
hole ich mir ich muss sagen bis jetzt
läuft mit google richtig gut könnte man
öfter machen wenn ihr das feiert so
sachen zu googeln und einfach das erste
davon zu nehmen dann geht auf jeden fall
mal daumen nach oben ich könnte das ja
auch mal mit so einer ja xxl episode so
machen das ist jetzt natürlich nur
erstmal das war so ein gedankengang der
cool war weil das hat er ein zuschauer
von euch form schlagen und ich will
jetzt einfach mal schauen ob das
überhaupt möglich ist
aber es ist wirklich das ist schon mal
gut heute sehr genial wie halten wir den
ganzen verkehr weiter irgendwas
geliefert werden muss dass sie einfach
da parkt oder so 9 auf die straße
korrekt ich stehe schon seit fünf
minuten er ich frage mich echt ob dieser
last sagen jetzt wieder was aus lädt
gebt euch dass man der stau ist so
unnormal lang hier leider mal wieder
absolut im halteverbot geparkt aber ich
habe denke ich mal wieder glück wird
morgen dann würde ich sagen machen wir
uns mal auf den weg zu guttenberg das
ist ihr gleich um die ecke heraus zu
hier sind wir auch schon ich glaube dass
herr das ist das genau
soweit ich bin schon wieder draußen ich
muss ein bisschen improvisieren gerade
sonst fällt gleich nachher hin erwiesen
gesungen ja ich hab's geschafft
naja also man muss auf jeden fall sagen
der laden läuft richtig gut da war es so
voll deswegen habe ich das jetzt auch
mitgenommen weil wir müssen ja noch
gutes am play machen also es riecht
anders heftig nach knoblauch ich hab ja
sogar glaube ich an das heftig gerungen
das war das dafür bestimmt heute schon
sagen glaubt selbst die pommes die hat
gefragt möchtest du knoblauch com ist
und ich so habe ich zwar noch nie vorher
gehört aber mach mal auf dem foto was
wir im internet gefunden haben sonst war
noch geiler aus als in echt aber ich
muss sagen also beschweren kann man sich
dann normalerweise eher weniger ganz
ganz wichtig ich habe natürlich auch an
der gabel gedacht hier friedberg also
checkt erstmal ob ist ein höchst
interessanter laden und ich habe jetzt
die braucht es war dass tui sahne oder
so mit tomaten guacamole sour cream und
pommes und wochen wasser dazu ich bin
wirklich mal gespannt ob mich das
überzeugt guck mal hier sogar mit
limette drauf das ist jetzt voll auf
meine sitze nein irgendwie ganz schön
schwierig zu recht muss ich doch sagen
wollte damit mit server cream habe ich
auf jeden fall schonmal gästen ist echt
lecker aber so eine art pommes mit
tomaten oder kam ohne knoblauch pommes
und das alles zusammen ich finde das
konzept von denen wirklich sehr
interessant und es schmeckt aufwand in
ordnung das ganze hat jetzt glaube ich
sieben euro kostet was natürlich alles
andere als günstig ist für eine packung
bommel aber gut das restaurant hat eine
super lage da muss noch ne pommes auch
sehr teuer seien und dass pommes
erlebnisses jahr deutlich höher als wenn
man jetzt einfach normale minister jung
nun kann man dass dieses youtube an der
immer ist und das ist ja auch echt eine
große portion man wird auf jeden fall
sagt was ich aber nicht so gut findet da
ist so viel so drauflos ertrinken
praktisch in der soße also so viel soße
kann man gar nicht essen trotzdem sehr
gut also ich kann es euch wegschnappte
okay leute wieder zurück in der wohnung
ich kann euch jetzt eine richtig große
story erzählen also ich hatte gerade so
glück auf dem rückweg
aber ich erzähle ich euch einfach mal
nicht weil ja ich weiß nicht ob das so
gut dass falls ist unbedingt wissen
wollt hält man den kommentare hashtag
neugier dann trage ich vielleicht ins
nächste video oder soll da nicht die
ausführliche form war so ein bisschen
also es ist wirklich ich kann mich sehr
glücklich schätzen
ich würde sagen ich habe mir das video
hat euch bis hierhin gefallen weil sie
sagt alex macht das auch meinen
xxl-version oder so sagt man nach oben
da weitere video wirklich einfach bei
instagram da hat sich alex beh oder
schreibt das hier unten in die
kommentare
aktive die glocke aber jetzt den kanal
jeden tag ein neues video
es war mir eine freude dieses video zu
produzieren und ich wünsche euch ein
angenehmer abend haut rein bis morgen 19
uhr